نرحب بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه نافذه
التحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري كما نتابع اخر تطورات
المشهد الميداني على الخريطه التفاعليه مع
عبد القادر ونبدا معك عبد القادر نعم زين
وعلي سانطرح من المنطقه الشماليه وحينما
نشير الى المنطقه الشماليه فنحن نشير الى
تطورات لافته في هذه المنطقه وتحديدا في
محور التفاح
وادرج الناطق الرسمي الناطق العسكري باسم
كتائب القسام كان قد تحدث عن استهدافه في
اربعه ايام نحو 71 اليه عسكريه على محاور
عديده ولعل محور التفاح والدرج يعد من
ابرز هذه المحاور حيث كانت القسام قد
اعلنت عن استهدافها لعدد من الاليات على
مستوى هذا المحور محور التفاح وتحديدا في
شرق التفاح تحدثت ايضا عن استهداف وفي
ايضا في حقل الغام عددا من الجنود الحديث
عن 15 جنديا قالت بانهم اردتهم بين قتيل
وجرح في هذه المنطقه وتحديدا بين منطقه
التفاح وتحديدا في جبل الريس الحديث ايضا
عن هذه التطورات في التفاح والدراج ياتي
بينما كان هناك ايضا حديث عن عمليه تراجع
او انسحاب او يمكن ان نسميها بعمل
تحرك لاليات عسكريه من التفاح والدرج
باتجاه جبل الريس وربما ايضا باتجاه هذه
المناطق وهي مناطق زراعيه وسط حديث عن
اعاده تموضع للقوات والاليات الاسرائيليه
هنا في منطقه الشمال كما حدث في ايضا في
منطقه الشيخ رضوان وايضا في منطقه النصر
هذه التطورات تاتي بينما كان هناك ايضا
حديث عن استهداف ل اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه
هنا في منطقه البريج مخيم البريج تحديدا
حيث كانت القسام قد تحدثت عن استهداف ايضا
مجموعات او تحش عسكريه في منطقه البريج
وكذا ايضا اعلنت ايضا سرايا القدس عن
الامر نفسه اي استهداف اليات عسكريه ولكن
ايضا استهداف لمجموعات لجنود لجنود هنا في
مخيم البريج وحينما نتحدث عن مخيم البريج
نحن نتحدث
عن
هذا المخيم الموجود في المنطقه الوسطى
والذي شهد عمليات قصف مكثفه وعمليات توغل
اسرائيليه في وقت سابق لكن التطورات
الميدانيه تتحدث عن اذ ل المقاومه في
محاوله لمنع هذا التقدم وبالمقابل هناك
عمليات قصف
للنصيحه المنطقه الجنوبيه وتحديدا خان
يونس لم تبتعد عن هذا المشهد خصوصا في
الشمال ولعلنا نشير
بالتركيز على منطقه الجراره هذه المنطقه
التي تقع الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه خان
يونس شهدت ايضا كمين اعلنته القسام لاليات
ولجن اسرائيليين على مستوى هذا المحور
استهداف لاليات دوما بقذائف الياسين ولكن
تحرك هذا المحور ياتي بينما كانت هناك
محاولات في ايام عديده للقوات الاسرائيليه
في محاوله للتقدم تحديدا الى وسط خان يونس
اذا هذه تطورات زين لافته على الجبهه
الشماليه تحديدا محور الدرج
والتفاح ولكن ايضا على المستوى الجبهه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا في خان يونس ولو كبرنا
الخريطه عبد القادر بنعرضها على الشاشه
سنجد ان الاشتباكات والالتحامات هي تقريبا
تريبا من اقصى الشمال الى اقصى الجنوب
سياده اللواء نحن نتحدث عن التحام في كل
المحاور تقريبا يعني القتال خلال الساعات
الماضيه اشتد خاصه في القاطع الشمالي
والقاطع الاوسط القاطع الجنوبي تقريبا هي
على نفس ايقاع المعارك في الايام الماضيه
ولا تغييرات على الارض
اي يمكن ال ان يتم التاكيد عليها اذا جل
المعارك هي في منطقه الشمال وفي منطقه
الوسط لكن المقاربات مختلفه كليا في منطقه
الشمال اذا نظرنا الى التفاح والدرج الان
هناك توجه
ل اعاده الانتشار او اعاده التموضع بغض
النظر عن المسميات لانه هذه الايام
القادمه ستحدد وهو الان يقوم بعمليه
انسحاب ومحاوله الانفكاك من حاله الاشتباك
عندما تبدا القوات في محاوله الانفكاك من
الاشتباك تكون مرتبكه خاصه في في وضع
القتال في المناطق المبنيه وضد جماعات
وليست جيوش اذا هذه الحاله تغري القوات
القسام وبقيه الفصائل على استغلال هذا
الظرف لانه يعتبر كانه وقت الضعف والوهن
لهذه القوات وبالتالي جاءت الفيديوهات
لتعزز ما نتحدث به من خلال الاصابات ا
التي تم ايقاعها في قوات جيش الاحتلال هو
الان يحاول ان يعيد تموضعه ولو مؤقتا في
منطقه جبل الرئيس والشعف وربما يندفع
لاحقا الى ما الى ما وراء ذلك لو ذهبنا
باتجاه منطقه الوسط بصوره عامه الاشتباكات
على اشدها ولكن المقاربه مختلفه هنا هناك
عمليات محاوله انفكاك هنا محاوله عمليات
تطوير عمليات للتوغل
البريج الشيء الجديد او المستجد في هذا
اليوم هو كان الهجوم من الشمال والشرق
بصوره رئيسيه وتقديم اسناد ناري في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لكن بدا الان يحاول ان
يضغط على مخيم البريج من الجهه الغربيه
وبالتالي اصبح وعلى هذا المخيم صغير مساحه
حوال 2 2 كيل ونص متر مربع وهو يقد يعتبر
الاكثر سكانا هذا الان يحاول الضغط عليه
من ثلاثه اتجاهات بالاضافه الى مناوره
بعيده المدى قياسا مع طبيعه الارض الى
الغرب من صيرات والى الزوايده من اجل فصل
منطقه البريج ولكنه لو سمحت تعدل السهم
سياخذ المغازي مع هذه المنطقه ليفصل
المنطقه الوسطى عن منطقه دير دير البلح
هذا بصوره عامه الواقع الميداني خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه فيما يتعلق بالفيديوهات
التي تابعناها اليوم لكتائب القسام وسرايا
القدس نحن نتحدث عن تنوع في الاستهداف من
استهداف لدبابات واليات متحركه واليات
ثابته حقول الغام نتحدث عن تفخيخ منازل
نتحدث عن السيطره على مسيرات نتحدث عن
التحام مباشر
بالجنود نتحدث عن قصف
بالهاون هذا التنوع ماذا يعكس سيدي يعني
الان هذه المعركه معركه كما قلت لك في
المنطقه الشماليه تحديدا هناك توجه لاعاده
الانتشار او لاجراء عمليات تراجع وبالتالي
هذا الوقت يعتبر وقت ضعف بالنسبه للقوات
المنسحبه ويجب على الطرف الاخر ان يستغل
باقصى ما اوتي من قوه لهذا السبب نجد ان
الفيديوهات هي معبره عن هذا الواقع تم
استهداف خمس دبابات بمقاربات مختلفه ل كل
دبابه في مكان معين منها الثابت منها
المتحرك وبالتالي تم استهدافها جميعا تم
استهداف مجموعه من ثلاثه اشخاص كما تحدثت
كم تم الحاق اصابات بال العديد من الجنود
يقدر ب 15 واحد في تفجير حقل الغام تفجير
مبنى كان معدا مسبقا وتم استهدافه عمليه
تفجير فتحه نفق استخدام قصف الهاون اسقاط
طائره مسيره فهذا هو الجو العام للمعركه
هي اي الجيش الاحتلالي يحاول ان يفك
الاشتباك فيما القسام يحاول ان يتابع خطوه
لانه لديه الوقت لديه الافضليه في
المهاجمه خاصه ان ذلك يرغب في
التخلص لدينا ايضا فيديو جديد من جباليا
نتابع وقائع هذا
الفيديو
اذا هذا استهداف بقذيفه التي بي جي في
جباليا ما هي ملاحظاتك على ما نراه حتى
الان يا سيدي يعني الان كما قلت لك هي
تقريبا نفس المشاهد بزوايا مختلفه لكن
ملخص ما
شاهدناه يذكرني بش بلحظه فارقه في التاريخ
العربي السادس من اكتوبر عندما دخل عبر
الجيش المصري القنال كان هناك انهيار في
الروح المعنويه لجيش جيش الاحتلال
وبالتالي تم اجتياح خط بارليف
وتم السيطره على كافه القاط الحصينه
والجيش المصري لاحقا دمرها باستثناء واحده
بقيت
كمعلم فكان ترد الروح المعنويه في تلك
الفتره رغم يعني باين الكبير في طبيعه
العمليه وقد يعارضني البعض لكن انا اخذ
البعد البعد النفسي والمعنوي يبدو لي ان
جيش الاحتلال في التفاح والشجاع والدرج و
هو يتمتع بروح معنويه تكافئ روح المعنويه
عندما عبر ابطال الجيش المصري قناه السويس
سيكون لنا وقفه مع مع الذي يحمل كل هذه
الاسلحه المقاتل الفلسطيني لس احنا بالامس
راينا
مقاتل لا يتحصن شيء لا يختبئ وراء شيء
يخرج
مباشره في الفضاء ويوجه قذيفته الى
الدبابه دبابه مركاب يا سيدي يعني الان
هذه المعطيات الميدانيه الموجوده يعني
عندما يكون في التفاح او في الدرج او في
غيرها هو يخرج من النفق يدخل في مبنى اي
يجد اماكن تساعده على التخفي لكن في كثير
من الحالات خاصه في المناطق الوسط والجنوب
هناك مسافات بينيه وبالتالي هذا السلاح
مدال اقصى 130 متر و وهو صاحب الفرصه
الواحده اذا اطلق رصاصه ولم ولم سيقتل
اطلق القذيفه ولم تدمر سيقتل بما انه صاحب
الفرصه الواحده اذا يجب ان يصل الى اقصى
نقطه ممكنه واقصى درجات الاتقان وبالتالي
في شوار وضعها تحت الدبابه الصقها في
الدبابه الى غير ذلك اذا هذه طبيعه ال
الظرف مكاني هو الذي يحدد صحيح وطبيعه
المقاتل ايضا ولا شك انكم كعسكري لكم
حسابات في التكوين المقاتل لكن دعنا ننوه
ايضا الى ما اعلنته كتائب القسام التي
اطلقت دفعه صاروخيه على تلا ابيب الساعه
الصفر من العام الحالي واستخدمت القسام
صاروخا من طراز ام 90 الذي يبلغ مداه 90
كيلومترا لكن هذا التوقيت والصاروخ له
كثير من الدلالات نتعرف عليها في تقرير صب
[موسيقى]
العصى صواريخ الساعه صفر هكذا باتت هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه الاكثر شهره في الحرب
الحاليه تطلق كتائب القسام دفعه صاروخيه
كبيره من قطاع غزه باتجاه وسط
اسرائيل جاءت بعد ساعات فقط من ترويج
الاعلام الاسرائيلي الى ان اسرائيل
ستستقبل العام الجديد وقد انخفضت القوه
الصاروخيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بشكل ملحوظ
لكن اسرائيل استقبلت العام الجديد بدفعه
صاروخيه من قطاع
غزه دفعه تحمل كثيرا من الرسائل العسكريه
والسياسيه تقول كتائب القسام من هذه
الدفعه انها لا تزال قدره على القياده
والسيطره تطلق دفعه صاروخيه في وقت واحد
هو الساعه الصفر في العام
20024 واستهدفت مكانا واحدا هو تل ابيب
تشير هذه الدفعه كذلك الى ان القسامه
قادره على التحكم فيما يعرف عسكريا
باقتصاد القوه اي ان الكتائب تختار الزمان
والكميه المناسبه التي تريد ان تضرب بها
هذا يعطيها طابعا من السيطره المحكومه
بالهدوء المؤدي الى التحكم في مسار
المعركه اذ ان صواريخها ليست مجرد رد فعل
على القصف الاسرائيلي بل اداه لاداره
المعركه وفق ما تراه المقاومه مناسبا
اللافت للنظر ان القسام نشرت فيديو يوثق
عمليه الاطلاق بعد 28 دقيقه فقط من
التنفيذ 28 دقيقه فقط كانت كافيه للتصوير
والعوده الى غرف المونتاج وتحميل المواد
الفيلميه واختيار المقاطع المطلوبه ورفعها
على الانترنت هذا يعني ان كتائب القسام لا
تزال قادره ايضا على اداره المشهد
الاعلامي العسكري بطريقه تؤدي الغرض
المطلوب اما في الرسائل السياسيه فقد كانت
الدفعه الصاروخيه من طراز ام 90 قبل ساعات
من اطلاق صواريخ الساعه الصفر نشرت
الكتائب ماده تعريفيه بمنظومتها الصاروخيه
تشمل هذه المنظومه ثمانيه عائلات من
الصواريخ المتنوعه تحتوي كل عائله على
صاروخ الى خمسه صواريخ وكل واحد منها معرف
باسم ومدى كان صاروخ ام 90 جزءا من عائله
صواريخ المقادمه الذي دخل الخدمه عام 2000
22 تنسب هذه العائله الصاروخيه الى الشهيد
ابراهيم المقادمه احد قاده ومؤسسي حركه
حماس وجناحها العسكري الذي اغتالته
اسرائيل بقصف صاروخي ابانا انتفاضه
الثانيه قبل 20 عاما ثمت صواريخ ضمن
عائلات اخرى في منظومه القسام يصل مداها
الى قرابه ثلاثه اضعاف المدى الذي يصله
[موسيقى]
المقادمه لكن الكتائب اختارت ان يعود
ابراهيم المقادمه الى اسرائيل اسما على
صاروخ في الساعه صفر من العام
[موسيقى]
2024 هل هل يمكن للرساله ان تكون اوضح من
ذلك لا يعني هذه كما ذكر اشاره واضحه جدا
انا لازالت الق هيئه ركن العمليات في
القسام تجيد وتتقن استخدام وتفعيل نظام
القياده والسيطره في كافه مستوياته
الاربعه كوماند كنترول كومنكيشن كومبيوتر
لا تزال تعمل بفاعليه وبالتالي تختار
الوقت المناسب لاحظ دقه
الاختيار هي رساله واضحه جدا انا ما قد
سياتي في العام
2024 قد ينسيك ما جرى في نهايات عام 2023
هي رساله تحدي واضحه رغم كل الدمار رغم كل
ما جرى رغم كل انواع الاجرام ولكن
المقاومه صامده وثابته ومتجذر في ارض غزه
وتحدث عن التهجير الطوعي تحدث عن انشاء
المستوطنات كما تشاء لكن القول الفصل
للميدان ا 28 دقيقه هي الوقت الذي يعني تم
استغراقه في اطلاق هذه الصواريخ والتصوير
كما اشار الزميل صهيب ونحن نتحدث ل لسنا
لا نتحدث
عن رصاصه تطلقها من من نفق نحن نتحدث عن
عمليه معقده ليس عمليه كبيره الان هذا
يعني هذا يدلك
على هدوء الاعصاب والثقه
بالنفس بالمقابل الافلام التي يعرضها جيش
الاحتلال اصبحت نوع من المسخره والادانه
وبالتالي هي للتندر وهو يعتبر نفسه الجيش
رقم اربعه تكنولوجيا في العالم هؤلاء
مجموعه شباب في في انفاق
قد يكون ي يقضي اياما على تمرات وقليل من
الماء ويقدم هذا ما يقدمه فهو يقدم درسا
للعالم يعنيي اقول يعني ق قرات جمله مفيده
اي يكتبها احد الاشخاص يقول الدول
المتقدمه التي تباهي بالتطور التكنولوجي
لديها عليها ان ان تنحني اجلالا لشباب
المقاومه في ظل الظروف التي يعيشونها
ويقدموا هذ الانجازات لانهم استطاعوا
بامكانهم المحدوده على الاقل ان يحيدوا
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه التي تنتج من قبل
تلك الدول المتقدمه مساله الصواريخ يعني
الجانب الاسرائلي يتحدث عن انها قلت وقلت
كثيرا وليست في اليوم الاول كما هي في
اليوم الاخير من العام الماضي لكن نريد ان
نفهم مفهوم يعني ما هو دور الصواريخ في
ترسانه المقاومه اكيد ليس دورها تدمير
اسرائيل يا سيدي يعني هي سلاح ردع و سلاح
ردع واضح وفي في اليوم الاول كان لها دور
دور مختلف عندما تم اطلاق 3200 صروخ
تم شل نظام الانذار العام على مستوى دوله
الكيان وبالتالي مع الامور المساعده من
عمليات تدمير الكاميرات وابراج الاتصالات
وغير ذلك كل كل ذلك واستخدام المظلات كل
ذلك ادى الى اندفاع 1200 مقاتل ودخلوا في
مد في انا اتوقع ان يعني مق المخطط لعمليه
طوفان الاقصى لم يكن يتوقع انها ستحقق ما
حققت من انجازات لانه وجد الجيش الاحتلال
في حاله الترهل فتوسع مدى الحركه لكن دعني
اقول هي اشاره واضحه ان المقاومه لا يعني
نقصت المخزونات نعم ام لا حدك لا امر
طبيعي جدا يعني اليست المخزونات
الاسرائيليه اوشكت على النفاذ لولا وصول
اي 320 طائره واكثر ما هي يعني واسرائيل
بكل مقدراتها وبذيل الاداري الموجود وبدات
امريكا ترسل
وعطلت يعني فعلت قانون الطوارئ عدم المرور
من خلال الكونجرس فبالتالي ستنقص الم نات
امر طبيعي جدا لكن لا ل لن تنقص
قيمه سلاح الصاروخ بيتر سر هو نقص
الاستخدام عددا وهذا امر طبيعي اذا
مستودعات
اسرائيل نفذت فهنا ستنقص لكن المخطط ذكي
جدا في القسام هو حتى ه في الل بدا يطلق
الصواريخ برسائل محمله بمضامين ورسائل
سياسيه في اليوم الاول كانت عمليه عسكريه
في الاسابيع اللاحق حقه كانت عمليات
عسكريه الان هي تحمل مضامين سياسيه فيما
يتعلق بالصواريخ التي تصل الى وسط فلسطين
والاثر هو هو لانه الاثر هو ان يدخل الناس
الى الملاجئ وطالما هنالك سف ان سيدخلون
الى الملاجئ ايضا على جبهه الطائرات
المسيره تم اسقاط مسيره في بيت
حنون طبعا هذه مختلفه
عن نعم هذه المراوح الاربعه تستخدم هي
تطوير ل هي تستخدمها القسام اصلا نعم نعم
يعني واستخدمت وبالتالي هذه المستخدمه في
البعد التجاري
ك لتوصيل طلبات وما شابه ذلك وتم تطويرها
كما تم تطوير ابابيل واحد والزوار و
اعطاها قدره اسقاط قنابل الار بي جي على
الاهداف الان هو تم اسقاط اكثر من طائره
يمكن اربع طائرات خلال الفتره القصيره
الماضيه لكن في منها ما از ما اسقط ب
بعمليه التشويش وعمليات تقنيه وفي منها ما
اسقط باستخدام السلاح ام هل هنالك فارق في
اي النتيجه يعني لا في النهايه هي المهم
الحصول يعني هذه الطائره ستقدم اضافه
نوعيه الى قدرات القسام في عمليات تطوير
ما لديهم لانهم القسام اصلا كل ما عرض من
صواريخ هو من خلال الهندسه العكسيه
وبالتالي الحصول على الطائره هذه او
الطائره الاخرى السكاي او ما غيرها هو
يقدم فائده اضافيه من خلال تطوير القدرات
التصنيعيه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا اللواء فايز
الدوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه